bassem bonjour alors c'est un à nouveau
naufrage au large des côtes tunisiennes
qui est devenu le point de passage vers
l'europe pour de nombreux migrants
bonjour dit effectivement c'était la
première fois que les garde-côtes ou à
l'armée à tunisienne affaire à ce genre
de sauvetage ont été appuyées cette fois
ci dans le par le croissant rouge
tunisien c'était la nuit de vendredi à
samedi 127 personnes dans une
embarcation de nombreuses nationalités
des égyptiens des erythréens et avait
des des soudanais des tchadiens qui sont
partis cette fois-ci non pas de la côte
tunisienne et de la côte libyenne du
côté de la ville de zouara ils ont longé
lia sur les côtes tunisiennes
objectif rejoindre l'europe
l'embarcation a coulé c'est la première
fois que ce genre de drames arrivent
très peu sombre ce sont ceux qui
arrivent à rejoindre les côtes
européennes ils ont été secourus par les
garde-côtes tunisiens appuyé par le
croissant rouge tunisien 127 personnes
au total
on reste encore sur un chiffre environ
de 43 a disparu ces personnes dans ce
bateau là avaient tous entre 3 et 40 ans
le gouvernement tunisien a annoncé que
les recherches étaient encore en cours
pour essayer de retrouver des survivants
après ce naufrage ce parfum fois qu'on a
affaire à ce genre de naufrage ce sont
des opérations qui s'accentue
progressivement et depuis plus d'un an
on observe bien sûr qu'il ya de plus en
plus de personnes qui essaient de
rejoindre l'europe via les côtes
tunisiennes via les côtes libyennes dans
l'air n'a pu se rendre sur l'île de
kerkennah qui au large de sfax qui est
un point de passage assez important pour
tous ceux qui veulent rejoindre l'europe
serait refait un peu plus une double
peau que personne surtout en afrique
airelles et puis c'est à partir de ce
point là olivier qu'ils essaient tous de
rejoindre le rox autorités tunisiennes
ont même renforcé les contrôles d'accès
à cette île l' objectif essayer de
réduire le nombre de traversées ces
traversées qu'ils sont généralement dans
des conditions assez spartiate s'est
organisée par des filières clandestines
avec moyennant beaucoup d'argent vont
pour ces personnes là c'est vraiment un
énorme pécule qui sait c'est d'amasser
pour pouvoir rejoindre l'europe
ils sont persuadés ils le savent très
bien que ça va pas être dans des
facile et que l'objectif ne sera pas
sûrement l'europe beaucoup de personnes
perdent la vie
les recherches comme j'ai dit olivier
continue les autorités tunisiennes elles
essaient de renforcer les contrôles et
notamment des partenariats sont en train
d'être fait encore et encore avec
l'union européenne notamment pour
pouvoir gérer ces flux migratoires
située à thouars qui passe
automatiquement par la tunisie à l'écho
qui viennent pour rejoindre l'europe
merci beaucoup bassem pour toutes ces
précisions ben hassen chébili en direct
de tunis